essence day kicks off a longtime ally of
President Trump is pushing Republicans
to step up and defend him former White
House senior adviser Steve Menon told
CBS News he's concerned that the
president isn't getting enough support
to hold back the opposition led by House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi the Democrats are
so united in this and and I look I
disagree with their ideologically but I
think Nancy Pelosi is a master of
political warfare and I think
strategically what she has done here is
from their perspective is quite
brilliant we need a sense of urgency
which is not there today on the left it
is their chief Washington correspondent
major Garrett is at the White House this
morning Forrest major Steve Bannon was
sounding the alarm in that interview of
yours you have new information this
morning about how the White House plans
to respond to this hearing are they
taking mr. Banyon's advice it appears
that they are the White House tells us
among other things that President Trump
will watch and tweet about the hearings
at least partially that other senior
officials will be watching and the White
House counsel's office will take the
lead in responding we are told in
real-time saying that the substance of
the accusations against the president is
weak and the overall process is deeply
unfair they will probably argue it is
unconstitutional the White House is
describing something that has heretofore
never existed a coordinated aggressive
and by the minute reaction strategy if
it materializes that will please at
least Steve Benton how should we be
watching this today major so it just
doesn't devolve into a total tit-for-tat
what are the goals of the Democrats and
the goals of the Republicans is if you
were watching what's your advice on that
well there is going to be some
procedural fighting and there will be at
times a look like it's just tit for tat
but what Democrats have to do is explain
to the country if they can that the
evidence that they have presented and
will present against President Trump is
so grave so serious that impeachment is
the only reasonable alternative the only
reasonable response because the actions
suggest a president who must be removed
from office that's what's implied by
impeachment for Republicans they have to
say look whatever evidence is submitted
to the public it is largely indirect
it's not the President himself and there
for if not invalid not rising to that
level of requiring impeachment as the
only response that's essentially the
tactics both side will be looking at as
this process begins and as Nancy just
pointed out we're gonna have lots more
hearings lots more witnesses after today
major our CBS News poll from yesterday
showed about 17% of Americans are still
undecided as we open hearings today what
are Republicans and Democrats doing to
move that audience one way or the other
well Democrats are gonna say over and
over today that they're serious and
somber about this process saying it is
helpful but you've got to prove it
everything about your orientation to
this question has to prove to the public
that you are being serious in summer and
there is a good number of people in our
poll who said they look at this process
and wonder if it's actually fair enough
if the president getting a chance to
defend himself that's going to be
another public measure of what the
public sees and hears and how it
evaluates it major Garrett Forrest major
thank you very much